[Music]
four in there well hey what's going
on Tom's just like farting around with
the thing and he I'm trying to make get
my [__] [__] rolling here get your
[__] together Tom get your [__] together
yeah this looks all right right what's
that am I too close is my face too
enormous no you're you're good you're
good yeah you don't have to be that
close to it if you don't I know but it's
like not reading anything well I am kind
of hey there's Dave we were just talking
about you yeah we're going to mannequins
tonight yeah that's why we're kind of
like look fancier than you well I look
fancier than you yeah you always look
fancy yeah I'm G to show you guys what
she looks like how many people we got in
there I don't know you you know I don't
I can't see it on the there's only six
in there I'll show we'll show it later
when so I imagine I imagine Dave that
you are going to mannequins tonight so
we will see you there later on this
evening yay yeah he's excited yeah we
haven't been in a couple weeks we went
to Barbarella last weekend for their
Halloween party which that was really
fun but here was the weird thing they
said on the announcement that they were
having a costume contest right and we
were there we weren't there until
closing but almost till closing and then
they announced like I saw they announced
on Facebook oh the winners of the
costume contest were BL but I don't even
remember who they were but it's just
kind of like when did you guys do that
they didn't they forgot about it they
forgot about it that unless they did it
like right before closed after everybody
left cuz I was just kind of like I I did
not remember that but you know what I
mean it was still fun anyway we just
like we weren't that concerned about it
I was just kind of like I thought you
know and actually not as many people
dressed up as I was hoping although I
don't know a lot of people did but a lot
of people didn't also I remember too
that like there was a whole group of
people there that were all dressed as
the Men in Black which I thought was
very funny like it was guys and girls
and they all had the exact same same
like the sunglasses and the suits and
everything and I was just like oh that's
cute that they got them all to do that
but you know I you know I I didn't
even I didn't even like dress up on
actual Halloween like I said because we
didn't really get that many
trick-or-treaters Tom put his Bane thing
on and like went and answered the door
and stuff but I'm just kind of like man
I'm not doing all that [__] because I
had I had a work to do and it just it
took so long to do the first time I was
like that at least I got a picture of it
like for Saturday night yeah so I'm kind
of EX I'm kind of excited about going to
manakins tonight um it should be I
haven't done anything in a while should
be fun yeah we have like I said we went
to Barella last weekend but yeah we
haven't been a mannequins in a little
while so it's like kind of a wild card
we'll see how [__] turns out Jen's
wearing the hottest outfit man ever I'm
gonna get her to stand up no I'm I'm
just going to show you here I'll show
you watch this this is going to get the
sex cam out the sex cam yeah yeah this
one's got a light on it oh he oh that's
right I
forgot
yeah um
turn the light on well yeah it would
probably look better cuz now it just
kind of looks like oh yeah well you can
see all the wires on the floor super
classy super classy yeah that's our
wires mhm and look look at look at what
you're doing look at what you're doing
yeah this is stand up this is what
happens when you give Tom the camera
when you give me the camera stand
up he thinks it's it's streamate he
forgets
yeah think my hair came out cool yeah
that's mostly my real hair turn turn it
sideways there you go let's get profile
put your arms up put them up yeah yeah
like that yeah so so they can see that
okay y look how [__] sexy that [__]
is look at her [__] I got her these
boots there uh black um felt yeah or not
felt what do they call it not velvet
right Black Velvet boots yeah kind of
velvety I don't real velvet but yeah
turn around side turn around the back
show the back Jesus Christ yeah can't
really see there you go all right I got
you okay thank you yeah now I can sit
back down like I
said what's that what's that oh oh [__]
sorry sorry like I said sorry he did
think it was streaming for a sorry sorry
just oh my God it
slipped s it slipped it slipped and it
got yeah it s slipped of course big ass
crash
right hold on okay that's good Tom you
are a delight
yeah a delight yeah I W well well
because I got ready before the show and
then I walk in the room like to tell Tom
it was like oh you know the show's on 15
minutes and he's like oh man I'm G to
have to like protect you at man kids
yeah cuz that's all easy access [__]
she's not wearing anything on her well
that's what I mean so it's just kind of
like Well normally like I said I'm
always kind of wey of wearing this kind
of stuff to mannequins just because you
don't want to get like [__] groped
yeah but every time that [__] happens I
got to [__] go crazy yeah so some
people might get their teeth caved in
we'll see yeah that might be
fun I'm a confirm psycho in that place
they [__] know better the only ones
that do that [__] are [__] dudes that
are new
yeah I mean everybody and meanwhile like
people that have been there for a while
like somebody starts [__] with like
not him yeah oh no yeah this is going to
end badly I ain't scared of going to
jail and you know security jumps on them
they know who I am I'm friends with the
owner so I could I could bounce somebody
there if I wanted to yeah they wouldn't
care if you bounce but um I could bounce
somebody they they would just go oh he
had to go okay yeah well they offered me
head of security there I was like no
I'll get locked up yeah you probably
would you probably would but you know it
does like I don't know I'm just cuz
you're the Bowser doesn't mean you can
break laws I you can't just like [__]
kill a [__] much as they might
deser [__] because I [__] start
swinging I mean cuz I get bad too and
like usually like the drunker I get if
like people are being real [__] I'm
just sitting there going man I really
want to [__] punch that dude right in
the [__] crotch
yeah maybe I'll do it just I'll pretend
it was an yeah I've Jen's seen me bounce
people before not really at that club
but at other ones [__] thr dudes off
the dance floor usually I just put them
in a headlock and start dragging them
backwards towards the door and they they
can't really do anything they're being
drugged backwards just so fast and just
throw the [__]
out it's always a dude big always dude
bigger than out yeah hi poy what's up
okay bam was in here early Bambi was in
here earlier too but she [__] off she
got mad
because I went to soak her little uh
food plate in the sink and I was going
to give her some more food afterward but
she's like why aren't you giving it to
me right now I am hungry right now yeah
she's got they said your hair is the Bob
she's got their goth hair on thank you
yeah this is almost all my real hair
it's almost all real hair yeah this is
this is real hair this is real hair the
only thing is not real is the braids
like those are like tied in but yeah
other than that it's all real the bangs
are real and everything yeah uh yeah
Tammy said looks better much better when
she stands up yeah I do like kind of
crunched up when I'm sitting down but
you yeah they said what read what DVD
Dragon says keep the fight strong
against the prostate industrial complex
yeah yeah I looked at the whole prostate
industry I [__] see how they do I see
how they do yeah they just want to poke
you in the butt they just want to
[__] give you a down it's just it's
just just like just like I do it's
just [__]
[__] it's just it's
just I looked at the American Cancer
Research [__] Institute and how they
and their recommendations and the whole
[__] industry involved around
prostate man Pro it really it's most of
the time it boils down to they're trying
to sell you a damn prostate massage you
could get that down at the [__]
rubbing tog if you wanted that it might
be a little bit more but you know yeah I
wonder is that like on the menu one of
these days one of these days we're going
to go in there and see what that's all
about
yeah they I wonder if they'd be really
offive prostate gets bigger as you age
it changes your PSA numbers uh it has
weird side effects like you the way
you're [__] piss and
[__] but they even if you have cancer
they rarely do anything about it because
usually it's like semi benign and it's
going to take so long you'll be dead
before that [__] takes over and then if
you do have [__] cancer it's like a
fast acting cancer you're a goner they
said you know so you might as well like
not even know they said early detection
makes no difference
so don't [__] with it man don't [__]
be [__] proding around on your [__]
[__] biopsies can actually trigger
[__] the growth of cancer and do
other [__] but it just they're sending
me down to have an
MRI and it's just because I my PSA
numbers were were high oh are they
really is that what they called about
today yeah that's that's okay but
they're sending me to Lake Nona just for
a [__] MRI that's no problem that's
not an invasive you know what I me well
yeah you just get in the and if there's
any [__] there man I want to would
know because it could be cancer in in
other
areas are they going to do a whole thing
or whole probably a whole like I would
probably cuz I forgot I forgot to ask
you because I know the VA called you
today but I forgot to ask that was they
said okay yeah but that's like three
months from now oh all right it's a long
time from now are you going to remember
no they they're going to send me a oh
they'll send you a thing in the they
always send you a thing in the mail yeah
so um but it's just they just start the
industry you know I'm being VA they get
paid to do [__] to me they get paid it's
part of their budget so they got to keep
the budget
high so what they do is is they just
[__] start prodding and poking and
[__] with you once you hit 50 yeah
but then it says right there says right
there in the Cancer Institute they said
you know if there's any problem in these
guys at 70 or older don't worry about it
they're like yeah cuz you've reached
life expectancy did you tell the people
at the VA like when they said they
wanted to stick stuff up your butt you
were like look I won't even let my wife
do that so
no no they never she never put it that
way well of course of course not of
course they're not going to put it I
would put it that way but that's she's
just a general practitioner
and when I told her that I did HRT and I
did a whole bunch of [__] steroids
treatments off and on she kind of
flipped her [__] you know what I mean
and I'm like I'm like yeah but I know
what I'm doing and well you don't know
what that does to this and that we're
going to have to check you out blah BL I
said do what you want but I said I can
refuse any treatment you offer me won't
affect my VA membership or my VA
payments or anything and then but I'm
not I don't show any symptoms of
anything you know she's well we got to
go check all this out you seem pretty
[__] healthy all
yeah I did have some side effects of
[__] Pro before HRT after it [__]
went down to minimal yeah and that was
just [__] like uneven stream yeah you
kind of had it you know that all went
away you did take test everything that
they [__] say about test and steroids
and [__] like that is wrong everything
now may be right if you're a teenager in
high school yeah don't [__] with that
[__] but once you get older your ability
to do [__] and take [__] your reaction
jeans might have something to do with it
too not everybody reacts the same way
but if any of you bro Jim Bros are out
there I can take [__] 1,500
milligrams of [__] MX fed [__] in a
week and not need any Aroma aromatase
Inhibitors no hormone blockers I don't
even need any cu I don't have I don't
have any strong estrogenic or Pro
progesteron uh reactions to any of it
which means that I'm just kind of like
resistant to that kind of stuff I guess
my system doesn't care that you put a
bunch of stuff in it it doesn't react to
it which that's great that's
great Dave says if you don't mind I get
gped all the time I want to be protected
by the Tom Protection Agency okay so you
need to like stand this this Dave Dave
yeah you want you want you want to stand
in front of Dave at mannequins yeah yeah
well you're you're a [__] Target man
as pretty as you are you're you know
that's going to happen I mean they got
people out there that love that big fine
look on a man you don't
know yeah but it's and people in there
are very people in there are very very
handsy yeah they're very handsy want to
rub up on
it try to do a prostate exam on
to tie it in with the other they're
going try to justify it just like I'm
just checking your prostate well it's
just it's it's like the equivalent of um
uh what's his [__] face Steven uh
Steven Seagal Ste like trying to like
look for breast cancer yeah in random
wom imagine if Steven Seagal was gay and
[__] thought he was a [__]
prostate examp and go around like like
sticking his finger at people's houses
like looking for I can see him doing
that that's like right in his wheelhouse
I feel like Tom I know you kind
constantly talking [__] about about how
I'm fat how my martial arts are
fake it's time for you to come down here
and do a prostate exam drop your
draws I'm going to go ahead and do what
my master taught me back in Japan back
in feudal Japan in the towa period yeah
cuz he's also a time traveler yeah yeah
yeah I'm going go ahead and Lube up my
fingers right now I got the best lube
known to man
Crisco butter flavored Crisco M make
your ass smell like cookies
right
now I want your hand over and I want
you and I want you to say
oh get your Chi going get your Chi going
so he's back there doing that and he's
got one of those bowls like those
singing bowls or like a gong or
something's okay God I'm trying to first
part of exam and my fingers aren't quite
long
enough I got something else else we can
put up
there hold on I got to take these pants
off oh yeah yeah yeah that's how he's
going to come do yeah yeah yeah oh my
God now try to angle your pelvis up a
little bit I want some back
arch which is funny because that's what
you say to me on I want some
back want some back arch on that so
that's so he
yeah oh my God I'm just like dude please
please do not leave me with the mental
image of you getting butt horked by
Steven Seagal yeah he got I will never
get aroused his belly is resting on my
back arch belly back there man and just
[__] painted on hair and Sh God damn
it and he's like thrusting and sweating
and stuff e he's back there are you
thirsty how about an Asian experience I
to like incorporate that
somehow Tommy you're so
gross see normally normally if it was
like not Steven Seagal like the thought
of that would be actually be kind of hot
but because but because it's Steven
Seagal I'm kind of
like I lose my lady boner you know
that's just how that [__] I want to see
some back arch like the other Tom Tom
Hardy his
back man Tom Hardy I'm I've had Tom in
here too well yeah of course couldn't
find
anything you couldn't find anything he's
a
ot9 he went back in time and cured his
own yeah that's how that works holy
[__] holy crap what do like we're we're
starting off early
tonight holy [__] I told you I was in a
weird mood today I guess you are too
yeah he is
ganther says uh they say if men live
long enough they would all have as
cancer at some point yeah I actually um
I think they told us that in my high
school science class maybe my college
science class where they were basically
like if people live long enough everyone
will get cancer yeah you know what I
mean although I think there's probably a
lot of cures for cancer just that
they're not
really not really [__] with it that
much it's not as deadly as it used to be
but yeah you can live a while with it
yeah there's probably C cures out there
we don't know about but probably
involves like genetic engineering and
Gene amplification where they take some
of your damn DNA and put it in an amp
fire make a bunch of it and inject it
back in there with some kind of
retrovirus which goes out strengthens
your reprograms all your cells makes
them all grow younger that kind of [__]
because a lot of that has to do with
errors in [__] cellular reproduction
like copying right there's problems in
the copies cuz you make copies and I
remember like but I mean this is pretty
simplistic obviously but it's just like
they're like well it's like making Xerox
copies if you make a copy and then make
a copy of that copy and a copy of that
copy it's going to degrade over time and
it's like your [__] is kind of the same
the resolution on your DNA is gone gone
down by a whole lot right they're like
obviously it's more complicated than
that but that's kind of the joke kind of
what it is just luckily you don't not
using most of that DNA anyway Jason S
said I saw video of family shoving all
the Halloween candy into the bags and
down the jumpers all they had to do was
just take the bowl yeah I didn't really
get why they didn't just take the I mean
you might as well if you're taking all
the [__] candy I don't know like Tom
showed it to me and I said that kind of
looks like a setup but maybe not maybe
not they were just kind of like hey it's
just here but yeah I don't know why they
didn't take this put the whole [__]
Bowl in there or just dump The Whole
Bowl in one bag and like sort it out
later on if you're going to be that much
of an [__] [__] you're going to steal
all the candy at least take might as
well steal the bowl too while you're at
it um let's see Danny ring said what was
Tom and Jenny's opinion on the 2014
remake of
Robocop did you like it or not like it
did we even see it
hm maybe Tom remembers I don't I thought
we watched it but now that I'm thinking
about
it we watched one remake of like an 80s
movie and we were just kind of like H it
was just kind of me but I I thought it
was RoboCop but maybe not maybe it was
something else but something along those
lines I don't remember if we ever saw it
cuz I kind of feel like look I'm not
averse to
remakes in General I just feel like if a
movie is RoboCop or if a movie is like
predator or something like that that was
like perfect the first time then don't
[__] with it you know what I'm saying
don't [__] with it there's millions and
millions and millions of movies that
were kind of good ideas but they like
kind of whiffed it cuz you know the
director sucked or they didn't have the
budget or whatever and it's just like
remake one of those like make it better
if you can't make it better then don't
bother he was talking about uh the the
candy video yeah yeah I'm going have to
uh apologize to the uh Eastern
Europeans I thought they were speaking
in some kind of Eastern European
Romanian or something but on the
comments they they said it's Spanish but
it's a Central American one of the
Central American dialects is Spanish
maybe like Venezuela or something El
Salvador that that's that's where they
supposedly were from I went back and
looked at it they just really biggest
one was like a teenage boy he's he's
like
51 they're 52 they're they're real
short
but that my house I'd have jumped out
and slapped a piss out of every one of
them those little
midgets and I'm a short guy I'm going to
call him a [__] slap P out well they
they look children too I slapped him I
mean they look like they needed a good
slap slap a piss out him just GNA say
like I said do they think they would do
I think they would learn no probably not
I don't care if they learn I just want
to slap them yeah punish the [__]
out yeah those are the kind of people
you can't trust they they steal or steal
other people's candy there for other
people yeah like I said I don't mind if
people just take one for Christ's sake
that's kind of what you're supposed to
do yeah well there a rich neighborhood
so they think it's safe it ain't safe in
here it's not my [__] neighbor two
hous one house not this now but the one
over here he's about [__]
6'4 he's rich as [__] white dude he's
got monster trucks his house is badass
got enclosed
pool I thought it may made some kind of
sports figure or something but it turns
out he's a he's a construction
contractor and [__] his whole
construction crew he recruits him
straight out of prison all right so he's
making good money and uh he's out there
[__] blasting his [__] shittiest
music you could [__] think of yeah
rattling our W it's like rap and country
western music combined into the same
song they got country western dudes with
[__] autotune and [__] it's just
terrible terrible [__] music it's not
good country and and and really there's
very little good country very I can't
really not I the only country I like is
like old [__] yeah shitty country that
sounds more like rockabilly all the new
country is just GH it just it makes me
want to kill myself bottom of the barrel
bottom of the barrel rap music and I
actually like rap but I like good rap
like back [__] you know back in the
day NWA and [__] public [__]
Cypress Hill and [__] [__] like that
[__] New Kingdom I liked them uh what
was the other one [__] them aot they
actually
had there was some creativity but some
of this rap they're playing now it's
just like shitty like they don't even
know rap music they don't have any
knowledge of music not not only they
don't even know rap music but why the
hell are they recording that it's
because just the recording industry is
just [__]
terrible yeah I mean I guess people are
still listening to it and buying it
imagine the worst rap ever just low
Talent low quality rap with the [__]
worst quality
country mixed together in the same song
I don't know any of these bands it's
just shitty really shitty and it's it
ends up being kind of like a really
lowbudget
Kid Rock and you know Kid Rock is would
be like [__] top shelf compared to
this he's okay I like Kid Rock Kid Rock
kind of stuff yeah but it's it's that's
Normie [__] but I'm just saying that
last song that he that last hit I
thought it sounded pretty
cool well that [__] looks like a
masterpiece compared to but he's that's
saying a lot it's [__] R well go down
there and [__] with him Watch What
Happens he he was [__] drunk as [__]
in there probably well that's what I
mean that would hurt you that's what I
mean it's just kind of like yeah I would
like to go over there and tell him to
turn that [__] music off because it's
rattling our [__] walls from two
houses away but yeah he's kind of one of
those guys that's like it's my house
I'll he come out with a [__] ar5 yeah
and he yeah he probably yeah this is not
a [__] this is Florida
all right and
it's some people say well this isn't the
wild west no it's much worse if you
actually look at the [__] violence
rates of the old west that's nothing
compared to today it's much
worse um this is starting to be Colombia
level [__] it's it's a lot more
dangerous than Brazil when I lived there
um but it's spread out the United States
is Big it's not
concentrated but in the South man and in
Florida man this is [__] just
Bonafide crazy
[__] um they're like kamakazi
some of them they don't
care that dude's Rich if you went over
there and [__] with him he'd gun you
down he probably would and honestly he'd
probably get away with it yeah probably
get away with it and he'd be drunk as
[__] get the [__] out of my house and
he'd [__] kill you and then the story
would change when the cops showed up he
attacked me with a gun he go down and
there'd be a gun there cuz he'd drop it
he'd have a throw down most guys have
guns that are just not really traceable
to them because they just pass through
so many hands used so you just throw one
of those at at the body down there and
there's no proof that that's yours and
no proof that it's his and they just say
yeah he came up with a gun dude shot him
end the
story they'd arrest you but you could
bond out yeah that's probably exactly
how that and he'd bond out and they'd
fight over it for about five or 10 years
and that dude probably knows all that
that's why he blares that horrible
[__] music over the whole
neighborhood yeah and nobody calls the
cops on although we were thinking about
calling the cops on him but I said well
technically you can't really call the
cops on him unless it's after 10 p.m.
yeah I mean yeah it's annoying the [__]
out of me and I can't doing that [__]
all night which just he was drunk and I
can't really well he started early he
started like four or five maybe earlier
than that in the afternoon and it's just
kind of like like I'm you know I'm in my
office and I'm like trying to work and
stuff like that I can't concentrate I
mean because it's just [__] blaring
yeah you know what I mean but you can't
tell them nothing because you
know sucks man and and Florida's I was
seeing a um an interview with the mayor
of uh Miami and he was seeing a lot of
people from New York were moving there
and uh they were scared especially the
ones out in the
country because they didn't feel that
they had any police
protection and he says if you live out
in the country he goes I know you're
from New York but if you live out in the
country get yourself a gun and go to go
to our little schools here and go take
it to the range and learn how
to defend yourself in your own
home people from New York would be
flabbergasted oh we'll never buy a gun
and then they're like okay then you're
going to be a victim because police
response time in in urban areas or
excuse me in rural areas like that can
be 45 minutes I don't even know where
the closest police station is to here
right I don't know where it is yeah so
everyone has to cover their own back
this is not it's probably not that far
away but I don't I really don't know
where it is no you would be long killed
by the time the cops would ever show up
especially out out in out in the rural
areas you'd be long
gone somebody wanted you they get you
they don't need a gun they could do it
with their fist or just a stick or a
[__] iron pipe so all this stuff
about well we'll you get rid of the guns
it be safe No One it'd be more dangerous
much more dangerous because women
wouldn't stand a chance at all those
thugs would run right through them and
and really they victimize the weak here
they don't really victimize the strong
so you the weak weak people need guns
more than strong
people I was going into the club and
they were checking me for guns we're
just checking you for guns with [__]
which gun my guns are right here and he
goes
yeah Allison says Tom is retribution you
could try to tie him down and give him a
special prostate exam yeah it's just
then then then he might learn well I'm
going to tell the doctor I said look
[__] if I need a prostate massage
they got those down at the rubbit tug
over here man [__] you know one of
these days are we really going to go in
there these
days probably not I don't probably not
probably not I'm kind of like weirded
out by it because it's like we always
pass it and it's like there's hardly
ever any cars in the parking lot it
always like the open sign is always on
every now and then you'll see one car in
the parking lot and I'm like well that's
probably the [__] that works
there you know where koywan is yeah
across the street that that tattoo shop
where yeah yeah where Su used to work
yeah I remember in that strip mall right
there got busted the one of the biggest
rubb and tugs of all time really did it
really right in there wow and it was
they got busted because the cops don't
care about it here really no I mean it's
it as long as you're kind of sort of on
the down low I don't really think they
give a [__] the reason why they got
busted is because there were about 20
girls in there and they were living in
there oh and so they were they had to
and and half of them were like Chinese
that's an untenable situation yeah half
of them were like Chinese girls the
other ones were just and were they there
like against their will no they were
just living in there you know uh the
Chinese girls lived in there because
they got they they they they bring them
here in [__] shipping containers they
do yeah and then they release them into
the wild and they end up working in
these Chinese run
businesses because they stick together
they don't ever learn English well
rubbing tugs are a Chinese they they
they have a lot of those and massages
and [__] like that Spa Asian spa it's a
rubbing tug all right I kind of feel
like most of I don't know what the
percentage is but I do kind of I I
always feel like most of them are and
well okay there there there was
one you know where uh where Al Altimont
was uh remember the hospital down in
Altimont yeah if you keep going down
there you remember we place when we got
yeos yeah okay well one two stories or
two buildings before that is the Asian
Spot was that the one with the blacked
out windows yeah that's a rubb and tug
well we figured as I was like there's
got to be a reason why all these windows
are blacked out like that yeah there's
about there's about a dozen Chinese
girls in there giving hand
jobs yeah and you easily go online and
they they guys are saying it and
reviewing it yeah so they're not really
like hiding it no they're not hiding oh
well now I have to look I don't remember
the name of that place that's across
from the you can find they going to be
reviews and everything they don't
they're not hiding it Florida does not
care but I wonder if like there's other
review cuz I'm kind of but like I said
it's always weird because we never see
like cars parked Florida doesn't care as
long as it's in private and and and
their sanitation is decent that you you
can't be having them girls live in there
they were living in there that's why
they well I agree with that I mean
that's [__] up don't don't let that
that's like I said that's some
sanitation issues that's some they had
it on the news though man [__] I saw
they was showed some of the girls that
work there some of the white girls that
work there yeah I didn't even remember
there was a massage parlor over there
but yeah it's like well the other buffet
that we used to go to kiwan there's a
like a um strip mall across the street
and there was a tattoo place over there
where a friend of ours used to work cuz
I went in there once like for a
consultation with her cuz she was going
to do a tattoo but like I we never did
it cuz I didn't have the money but um I
didn't know there was a massage paror
over there but I know exactly where
you're were talking about most of the
South and probably the most United
States really I guess if you look at
they really don't care about
prostitution as long as it's not out in
the open and it isn't industrialized and
they can't they don't want any Street
Walkers they can't control it because of
the internet now a girl can do what she
wants she doesn't need pimps she doesn't
need any agency she doesn't need
anything she there are little websites
that can go on there and they can be a
an independent agent through there place
like [__] trist do which like I said
I don't have a problem with that at all
if that's what you want to do and you
want to make money like that then that
is entirely up to you like I said
obviously if you're being forced into it
then that's a whole different issue yeah
you shouldn't be forced into anything
the the the age the age of Guerilla
pimping has gone unless you're an
illegal immigrant
because then you don't have any
protections right yeah and you're
rubbing elbows with organized crime and
that's that's who brought you into the
country anyway like those Chinese girls
that end up in those rubbing tugs got
here because they agreed to work here
work there right they they paid their
passage and they come over here in
[__] shipping containers a friend of
ours bought
one I told a story before yeah bought a
Chinese girl and he did yeah yeah
shipped her here in a shipping container
we found out we found out later on and
we were like wait what yeah what he
tried to give her to me yeah yeah she
was cute but I didn't want her and
[__] and she and she was uh she was
we know some she was in love with him
she was in love with him she was yeah
and uh we know some weird ass people I'm
telling you right now and here's the
thing she was a school teacher yep she
was he was too he was too and but
she you would think that might still be
when you say he bought a woman you're
thinking well [__] she must be chained
up in the basement no he she worked as a
school teacher yeah yeah she had a job
and [__] and she was yeah had a job is
making money and yeah it was a weird
[__] situation yeah and they were
kind of like in an open relationship and
he was trying to get rid of her so he
could date other women he was kind of
like sick of her but then they got then
they started to they rekindled it evid
because I guess while she was over there
like I guess he kind of bought her not
just for sex but to like clean up his
place and like cook for him and [__]
like wasn't she like kind of the maid
too I feel
like sort of she was like a he bought
her as a
companion but she had to have good
qualifications she had a good education
that's so weird she was actually a nice
person like we met her a few times but
yeah they're not married and she's not
legally here there all kind of [__]
crazy but yeah there was a whole thing
there was a whole thing like this was
right around the time we started going
out or like a little bit before where he
was trying to give her to Tom cuz he was
like tired of her so they we having this
whole conversation well you want her you
can have her if you want and Tom's like
no
thanks like it's a [__] a weird thing
to ask somebody you know what I mean but
uh he's she's like no that's that's okay
you just you just keep that but like
it's like I haven't seen him in a long
time Allison said tacky yeah you know at
the very least um yeah it it was a
really really weird situation like I
we've been in some really weird
situations it's like it's weird because
it didn't seem
well okay I'm not going to say that it
didn't seem weird at the time because it
totally did but I'm just saying that
when we talk about it now and you just
kind of say it out loud like that I'm
just like holy [__] that was like really
[__] weird and it's like we thought
it was weird at the time but it wasn't
as big a deal I guess so like now that
we talk about I'm like holy [__] [__]
I can't believe that like that [__]
happened I just still I can't believe it
still I don't know like I said it's just
totally weird uh Bryce said cops need to
leave prostitutes alone I agree those
women are just trying to make money they
didn't they don't hurt anyone yeah
exactly I don't really have a like I
said as long as no one's being coerced
and as long as they're not underage um
if women want to make money like that
then more power to them man we actually
we were just talking about that um the
other day because Tom was saying I don't
he was listening to some uh podcast or
something like that and the guys were
kind of a little bit kind of making fun
of girls that made money on like only
fans or streamate or ChatterBait or
whatever and and it seemed clear from
the way the guys were talking that they
didn't
really they didn't really seem to have
much uh empathy or sympathy for these
women and they also didn't really know
what the [__] they were talking about I
don't think because look like we've well
um Bryce was saying that he thought that
cops should leave prostitutes alone and
like I said yeah I agree they're just
trying to make money and I said you were
telling me the other day that you were
listening to somebody that was talking
about like kind of making fun of women
that made money on only fans or
and I was just kind from from people and
him that have
streate um one it's much harder than you
think it is yeah like it's not easy
money for real when when the business is
slow man drives you [__] crazy it's
not and and we've talked about this
before like it's fun but you don't know
what people are going to ask you to do
um you have to kind of like perform like
on the fly like you have to come up with
[__] on the Fly
a lot of it is just kind of sitting
around waiting like kind of getting B
and try to like entice people into your
[__] and everything like that so it's
not um and then once the people come in
you have to
really you have to really kind of like
work them you know what I mean yeah and
here's the thing and and the guys that
are by the
show most of them are only going to be
in there five to seven minutes because
that dude [__] shows up pecker in
hand he's [__] almost there he wants
to save money yeah I mean usually have
time to really do anything right so uh
you know as a guy you know what I mean
it takes you a while to [__] get in
into the thing he's long gone by then so
you have to fake a lot of [__] yeah
because I mean you have to they don't
seem to care it's just it's just yeah
they don't seem to it's like as long as
it looks good and like the performance
looks good but yeah you have to think
it's like we've been sitting around like
you know twiddling our thumbs for like
an hour and a half like when this person
shows up so yeah in extreme cases yeah
so we kind of have to like really kind
of get our [__] together and like make
it look good like you know what I mean
but then you have some dudes show up
though and they'll do a whole 20 minutes
yeah at like [__] $6.99 a minute yeah
so you
know you can make a decent change on
that yeah you never know you never know
what's going to happen you never know
like what and like I said not knowing
kind of
[__] it is kind of it's kind of
stressful it's kind of stressful and
then uh part of the part of the the
thing the obstacles that me and found in
in in that particular side
gig is that if you don't have a long
history behind you and a lot of regular
customers you're going to be waiting a
lot yeah but my friend's my friend's
wife Amy uh what's Quinn yeah Amy Quinn
that's her porn name she has a lot of
[__]
fans she'll only work six hours three
hours and then three hours 3 hours in
the morning and three hours in the
evening she'll pull down on a she was
averaging about 400 bucks a night yeah
she was pulling at about $1,500 a week
1,500 a week yeah just for just on that
three hours here three hours there yeah
yeah six hours a day but she has lots
and lots and lots because she's been
doing it a long time and she has a lot
of a lot of video out there she has a
lot of video like she's been doing it a
long time right and you know video sales
even for a
pro they don't really add up to much um
she's got a [__] [__] ton of
hundreds of videos and they don't even
make a thousand dollars a month off
those videos yeah you only make like a
buck or two like off each video that's
that's the profit couple bucks per sale
I mean if it's long you can sell it for
more yeah but you still only get like a
cut you know what I mean the video is
just an advertisement yeah just kind of
showing that you have we probably should
need to make more videos but you know
what I mean cuz we have the video is
actually the funnest to make yeah I I
really like making the videos because is
yeah you can do whatever you want like
you're not like cuz I'm always kind of
like stressed out because you know I'm
kind of an introvert as it is but then I
have like a weird a little bit of like
an exhibitionist streak also but the
thing about it is that you never know
what the person's going to ask and like
if they ask for something specific
you're always just kind of like oh [__]
am I [__] this up like I'm ruining it
for them you know what I mean so it's
like like that's always like really
stressful for me because I want them to
have like the best experience so I don't
want to be like am I messing up am I in
the wrong position am I like this the
other thing so yeah I'm like always
worried about it yeah and for Jen it's
not natural she doesn't have stage
trading all right I do and a lot of
improv experience yeah I mean I used to
sing but I didn't really do like she's
kind of learned it on or anything I was
I was doing it at an early age you know
so I can do I can do that [__] on the
Fly it's not as natural for her and Jen
was never a stripper which that's that's
they they come equipped with a bunch of
skills that are real useful for uh for
doing cuz it's a similar kind of thing
even though the people aren't there like
yeah you know if you look at the way
strippers move and just the way just the
way they even make
video everything
is very much hand gestures the angle of
feet uh everything's uh there's just a
stripper move stripper Poise that they
do and you can tell
the difference
between erotic performers who have a lot
of stage experience on stripper poles
and girls that have just been working
from from home the girls that work from
home have a very
workmanlike body
language girls that came off stripper
stages are real elegant or real sexy
because their emotions are stylized and
accentuated you know because they know
what people want to see yeah they know
how to move
pretty and a lot of it is pretending to
be pretty that's a lot of [__] what
the visual art of pornography is about
moving like you're pretty being shot
like you're pretty everything is and
it's it has nothing to do with the sex a
lot of the [__] it looks great on film
but if you were actually do that you you
it wouldn't be wouldn't feel that like I
said I kind of feel get enough thrust in
there there's not quite enough friction
from that angle just that's kind of why
I'm always just kind of like that's I
think that's why a lot of women don't
really like porn all that much or at
least as much as men do because most of
the time I'm sitting there going man
that would be so
uncomfortable like that would not feel
good at all like it looks good on camera
and I'm sure like the dudes like seeing
that because they can see the woman's
body from those angles and stuff but
it's just like you know coming at it for
me like relating to the woman I'm just
like oh my God she must be so [__]
uncomfortable right now the guy looking
at the video wants to see intercourse
and penetration happening but he can't
close off the guy
can't be at an angle where he shuts off
the actual penetration with part part of
his body so you have to be doing [__]
from weird angles that looks good on
camera but if you were to actually do
that yourself like man you're kind of
[__] her sideways a little bit and
you're like not this is not really
feeling all that getting very deep you
know you're only going in you know
couple inches yeah so and it's because
it's for the cavern
yeah so you know that's just kind of a
whole other thing too genx Jason says
Tom and Jenny susing the Banshees The
Cure or depes mode which do you like
best susing the Banshees all day yeah I
mean I like all of those bands I'm not
I'm not saying that but I think like out
of all of them I think Susie the
Banshees is the best band over close
second would be cure the Cure is [__]
really good especially the pornography
album yeah I like their [__] that [__]
is hard as [__] real goth real dark and
that was really their best album they
said we're not going to do that again
because it's everybody's telling us to
go down that direction and and that
we'll go down that's still my favorite
album of and that came out in [__]
1982 you never heard the The Cure get an
album what was it 198 what 1982 1982
called pornography the album has nothing
to do with pornography that was just the
name of the
album it is just Gothic as [__] real
dark
yeah what's oh somebody sent thank you
Bryce appreciate it very much I almost
forgot to do a super chat but you didn't
thank you very much sex work is work I
think guys usually don't know that yeah
I think a lot of guys maybe don't I mean
maybe just people that are kind of
casual porn connoisseurs um don't
realize how much actual work does go
into that yeah in the sense of well and
especially for the wom like wearing
certain things like wearing wearing [__]
that like I said they probably wouldn't
be wearing if they didn't have to be on
camera like super uncomfortable shoes or
super uncomfortable clothes or whatever
and um you know being in like super
uncomfortable positions just because it
looks good on camera you know what I'm
saying yeah so I kind of feel like a lot
of the times I don't know it's like some
women do get off on it I guess different
kinds of it but yeah what women like I
do too sometimes but it's not really
like I said if I wasn't on camera it's
not AR what I would be doing women
aren't as visual we're a lot more
imaginative they rather read something
to get them off I yeah I've always you
kind of started liking uh uh uh animated
I do like the animated horn like yeah
it's like something out of video game
like I don't usually watch it on my own
like if you're not there yeah but um
when we're working streamate we'll have
some animated yeah we have another
laptop and that's like the porn laptop
so we just have it going like we'll put
on like a 2hour compilation or something
like that just to have it going in the
background to kind of keep the the mood
up or whatever yeah keep the dick up too
keep the yeah keep well that's what I
meant I was I was trying to use it you
is but um well I I found that I liked
the animated porn like I said because
it's not a real person so it's like if
they're in an uncomfortable position it
doesn't bother me you know what I mean
it's more of a fantasy element so it's
more of a fantasy element and I do yeah
and I like like that about it too that
it's like it doesn't have to be a real
person it could be like a monster or a
fairy or something like that and I was
like that's pretty cool yeah they got
the World of Warcraft characters I like
that one actually yeah [__] Vamp
werewolves having sex with elves and
[__] [__] go crazy yeah I kind I kind
of like that actually and and you can
like break all the tabos cuz it's
animated it's not like real people or
anything like that it's video animation
and the proportions are impossible legs
impossibly long uh boobs possibly too
big just but they got the damn the
animation algorithms for motion that
sometimes they get them down pretty well
it looks it looks pretty good yeah some
are better than others like I said dep
on what artist is doing it yeah but they
have whole compilations of them are
really good yeah there's a good there's
a good place where you can get all that
[__] it's called was a rule
34. or net or something you you'll find
it rule
34 and it's just 34 rule 34 just search
it and there there's there's one of will
show up and um there's all kinds of
compilations and [__] on there a lot of
it looks like cutcenes from [__]
high-end video
games yeah a lot of them are kind of
because I don't really play video games
all that much or um or anything
so yeah I don't really recognize a lot
of the well I do but it's like I don't
know exactly who they are a lot of them
are video game characters but I'm just
kind of like I don't know I I kind of
like the whole like wom getting [__]
by five werewolves yeah yeah as long as
it's animated like I said if it was real
life I don't know well obviously where
she's a vampire right you know what I
mean yeah like so and they can get away
with a lot more in animation CU like I
said it's not real people so you're not
like oh man that's [__] up you know
what I mean that they subjected a person
to that
yeah and the werewolves are like
something out of damn [__] uh the
howling big [__] bipedal werewolves
yeah or sometimes he's just in wolf form
too DVD's right says Chinese women
shipped in containers doctors after your
booty hole homicidal construction
workers blasting music 3D characters
[__] crazy world out there yeah crazy
show yeah because that's all the man
we've been on less than an hour we've
already covered all of those topics well
it's just like I'm saying some some you
you'd have people from Europe or up
north or something say this isn't the
wild Westy yeah it's much worse it's
much more wild kind of insane yeah it's
always been insane yeah I don't know why
well I well I do know why one it's hot
as [__] down here and it's just it
drives you crazy if you live down here
you would
understand it's the crazy people from
everywhere from everywhere come come
here and they come into a Southern
Culture which is pretty wild to be and
then there's a big Central American or
Cuban influence which Latin influence
which of course wraps it up you know and
but most of the South is pretty crazy
New Orleans area [__] crazy as [__]
Atlanta [__] crazy we're kind of
crazy Atlanta is the southern version of
New York City it's it it's big it's big
metrop [__] crazy it the south is so
awesome our main city is basically
called Atlantis with Atlantis is what
they're [__] talking about come on
down to Atlantis [__] yes Under the
Sea yeah yeah Oscar says hey Oscar
what's up if women weren't visual slobs
who aren't Rich would be getting laid
left and right I would submit that slobs
who aren't Rich are getting laid I don't
know about left and right but they do
get laid slobs that are rich get laid
Yeah well slobs that aren't Rich get
laid too uh yeah depends on the
situation depending on the
situation if he could talk his way into
it yeah he can I'm not saying that women
aren't visual across the board I'm just
saying we're not as visual as men are
they're not as sexually stimulated by
they're more stimulated by [__]
status really when it comes to the guy
not so much how he looks it's just what
his status is she he Cool's [__]
funny [__] he's got money everybody
respects him he's got power they're more
into that yeah I like looks don't matter
as much I think as they do celebrities
get laid sure yeah like I'm not saying
looks don't matter I'm just saying they
don't matter as much as they do to dudes
probably but
um and honestly like I said I don't like
I do like some porn although I do tend
to like animated porn more and I like
kind of lesbian porn and gay porn and
stuff I don't like a lot of straight
porn just you know for reasons I've gone
into before but um honestly like [__]
that I really like I like written [__] I
like erotica like and a lot of women
like that there's a huge huge huge
[__] Market I think the last time I
looked written erotica I think 85 to 90%
of the purchasers of that are women so I
think that's what that is because you
like to use your own imagination you
like to like insert yourself into this
situation that you can imagine the way
you want to imagine it like if you're
seeing it in front of your face then
everything's done for you and it's not
is personalized I guess you're like look
I don't know that [__] I don't
know that chick it's like you know what
I mean who are these people you know I
don't know them I'm I don't know
anything about the situation I don't
know anything about the context so it's
kind of harder to get into is all it is
it just seems very like I said a lot of
straight porn seems very clinical to me
it just seems very clinical cuz it's
just two people who you don't know and
you don't know the context of the
situation and you don't have the
relationship between them it's just two
people like [__] and you're just kind
of like okay like you know what I mean I
missed it what you talking about no I
said that at least for me I kind of feel
like a lot of straight porn to me seems
like really clinical I said because it's
just like two [__] I don't know
especially '90s like [__] each other
and I'm just kind of like I don't I
don't know the context of it I don't
know the relationship between them and
it's just kind of like I don't there's
there's no depth to it so I'm just kind
of like okay it's two people [__] it
just seems very mechanical yeah the
driest would be '90s VHS por it just
seems really mechanical yeah it was it
was definitely well it's it's a fake
product it's just a product uh now it
got better later on when you had people
who when cameras were cheap enough where
people could record their own yeah so
amateur porn is actually a lot you're
right well there were also people that
were a mixture of the two like they had
one called Shane's World which was like
the beginning of reality porn and it was
she was a porn she was a porn star a
stripper that started to do porn with
her boyfriend and they would record it
all with cameras that they had and they
would invite other people over the
industry and they'd be in the hotels and
at Resorts and [__] and it was and at
parties where they're all kind of having
sex and it wasn't scripted it was
reality porn that was a lot better that
was the beginning of like what what they
called later on Gonzo yeah you know um
and Shane was cute she was a cute little
blonde and
um all the female porn stars liked her
so she could get she could get them to
come over and shoot
scenes and it would do it like in a
vacation type setting so you know
there's a lot of inst filler in between
them drinking and talking and pulling
jokes on each other and then all of a
sudden sex breaks out and they're
recording and it it does see it was a
lot fresher because a lot of it was
spontaneous they were
partying see I like that kind of [__]
more yeah and that's why like I said I
like amateur porn and I guess it's not
just me because like that was is more
popular just that the Mark is flooded
because it's just kind of like well
those people would probably be [__]
each other anyway even if the camera
wasn't on and it's like that's kind of a
lot more I was at least I know they want
to do it and rather than just like
getting paid to do it what's big now's
amateur type porn women recording
themselves who are married women
recording themselves having sex with
dudes that they're not married to in
hotel rooms with uh while the husband is
at home watching the kids and there's
like subtitles they're talking about
that and that's her whole thing they
call Hot wiing yeah yeah we were talking
about that other too hot wi that whole
[__] and they those girls will run a
only fans and they and then they'll
they'll run a mini vids and they'll run
all these different things and they're
they're hot wife and and the dude's in
the husband's into
it had one named Cassie Bender she'd
[__] sneak off these black dudes and
[__] the bigger the better sneak off
yeah yeah it was all set up and PE the
the fans are like what bet her husband's
[__] you know he must be suffering
and [__] then they made a video of him
watching her porn beating it to it he
loves it he just totally into it yeah
totally into it they got some freaky
dudes out there yeah you know what I me
[__] because I kind of think because we
were talking about this before I said I
think yeah naturally but like I said I
you know and this is a generalization
obviously because everybody's different
but generally yeah dudes don't like to
think about their wife or their
girlfriend or whatever like [__]
other dudes yeah but some dudes get off
on it yeah though big time
and you thought and I and I think this
is probably correct I'm not a
psychologist or anything but you said it
was probably because they were they had
a fear that the women would cheat on
them or that women were going to cheat
on them so they decided instead of
getting all upset about it they were
going to eroticize it as a way of kind
of like overcoming that fear because
they're like oh the worst has happened I
can see it and I'm in control of it and
I'm in control of it like I can watch it
and I'm kind of beating off to it and
it's just kind of like so it's like that
makes sense to me another another
possibilities it could could have been
that earlier on in his life he got
cheated
on and it upset him yeah so to conquer
his fear of it he Incorporated that into
into his thing like this is totally
Politically Incorrect what I'm going to
tell you but the psychologists have said
this on some of the programs that I've
watched they could confirm it trauma
people involved with people that went
through trauma if a woman was sexually
assaulted she will tend to be attracted
to the GU to the kind of guys that
assaulted her I have heard that yeah and
it's because well it's a coping
mechanism way now in control she's
trying to in get into control of
something that was a trauma to her yeah
because it was something that was taken
out of her control so she's trying to
like get on top of it like I yeah I
understand that she trying to turn it
around like she has power over it now
she like a guy like this did you know
sexually assaulted me in my own home if
I can choose a guy who's like that and
do it willingly it almost kind of erases
what happens because now it's like that
I get that yeah I mean that seems
totally that's understandable totally
mentally unhealthy to do that if you ask
me it it is but in a way everybody needs
to deal with their [__] in their own way
and if that helps her yeah then who's to
say right yeah it's probably not super
healthy yeah um but actress Fran dresser
was like
that she was like that I heard that
about her yeah you you can find her
story you'll
see yeah that would be kind of like
messed up but like I said that's totally
understandable like why that would
happen though I get it yeah I get it
Bryce says when it comes to my girl I
don't hate or get off on my girl [__]
other guys it just doesn't bother me
okay said we're open okay yeah well as
long as you get something out of it yeah
you know um I mean some people are not
bothered yeah we have
friends there's one of them I'm thinking
of right now is a couple that work for
Disney
Corporation and uh they were in an open
relationship and they' sleep with other
people in front of the other and
sometimes they'd all just be in the big
cluster right they didn't give a [__] um
but that was the arrangement and it was
now that relationship didn't last that
long they were married they got they got
divorced yeah so but there I think there
are some other people that can deal with
that
or there are some people that can do
that and they only do it a couple times
then it loses its right loses its u in
they lose interested it and they just
stopped doing it they was like ah well
we did that it wasn't it wasn't all that
now the rship might break up later but
it has nothing to do with that yeah it
was just some people were just like who
gives a [__] yeah yeah yeah we did that
it was there was no big deal yeah
they're like that yeah I think things
are less of a big deal when you actually
do it but I don't know I I kind of feel
like I'm sort of yeah everything I've
done I thought was a big when I actually
did it was like oh there's nothing to
that really yeah well you build you
build things up in your mind right yeah
yeah when we first started doing
streammate like we were kind of like
really nervous about it it's like oh my
God it's going to be super weird and
stuff like that but it really wasn't
weird it wasn't weird want like oh okay
it's just this it's like yeah okay it's
really not that big of a deal it's
really not that strange um but yeah I
don't know it's just kind of like I'm
I'm always just kind of like well if
[__] happens in the
moment um you know [__] happens
I
don't I don't know I'm not I'm not super
into like thinking of the idea of you
like [__] other people like I don't
really like that
idea um and you probably don't like the
idea of me [__] other people but it's
just kind of like I don't know you never
know what's going to happen like I said
it's all a situational kind of thing I
just don't think about it yeah I don't
really think about it either I'm just
saying like I grew up doing that kind of
[__] right for me all that started in
high school
me and my best friend would be [__]
going to the movies in a car on the
drive-in double dating we'd be having
sex with both our girlfriends in the
[__] in the car the girls talking to
each other passing cigarettes while
they're getting [__] and [__] just it
was it was it was just a bunch of
friends you know yeah and then sometimes
the girls would [__] go I'm getting
in the front say okay you come back in
they
switch you have a second but they we
they weren't girlfriends though yeah
they were just friends that we knew
you know what I mean we didn't have any
exclusive claim on any of them yeah well
some we did if it was your girlfriend it
was kind of like a little bit of a
different yeah but we' tease the [__]
out of each other like me and my best
friend we [__] threatened I'm G
[__] steal your girlfriend type of
deal okay yeah that's pretty common I
think to do that and
then Steve was always going like you
know I [__] your mom right I was like
no you didn't he [__] he had me go
cuz my Mom liked him and I was like he
had me going for a while did you really
goes of course and and he said it so I
was just like that [__] did did
he did you ever find out did he actually
did he did but see we got into this war
over can you prove it I was saying I was
I I did two things first I was saying I
was G first thing I said I was gonna I
was G to [__] his little sister for that
she was probably about 15 at that time
that's was probably about 17 yeah so
it's it's not weird yeah it was that not
I was we were [__] around with girls
that brown that age only like yeah yeah
his little sister and he he get mad
about that yeah okay Brothers brothers
are very protected their sisters you
don't you don't have any sisters so you
don't so I backed off that and then
later on when he was talking about how
you know what was like [__] my
mom what he had like a whole [__]
story about yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know he's going kind of reminds
me that time your mom was BL me like
what [__] you that [__] didn't happen he
goes dude man he just go on and on you
he just came up with him like that's
pretty awesome actually well
um oh my God one summer I [__] I just
said oh by the way I know all the [__]
between you know you and my mom and [__]
that you said this happened like I got
even and he's like yeah sure you did and
then [__] like Tim so how'd you get
even and I said I [__] your
mom yeah was his mom hot no she's cute
she was cute know yeah yeah yeah her
name was uh Karen I think her name was
Karen yeah oh God really was she an
actual Karen no okay she was a little
munchkin she was skinny I would
considered her an old woman but she was
probably only like 41 at the time well
that's what I mean you're a teenager
everybody seems like an old person now
that you're now that we're in our 50s
we're just kind of like oh I guess that
wasn't old after all
yeah so I had him going for that for a
while you [__] cuz yeah and I said we
can't and he says I had to keep the [__]
on wrap so don't don't make a big deal
out it [__] Greg finds out he might
[__] kick my ass that was his stepdad
Greg did you f did you [__] his mom
no no but I pretended like I well I have
to ask because it's like I don't know
you might have oh it was possible I
could have that's what I mean totally
could have and he probably could have
fight with too I know my mom know how
she is well that's why I was laughing
cuz I know your
mom's that's why I was kind of laughing
about it my mom loved him [__] was mom
thought he was the great the greatest
[__] kid of all times you
oh my God yeah but uh no so I had him
going on that one for a while too
eventually I had I had to let it go you
I know you're just [__] with but
there's that teenage male paranoia that
it might that it could have happened
because we were doing [__] crazy [__]
you know that's I mean it could have
happened you could have [__] his mom
yeah yeah that totally sounds that's
very on brand for you to yeah yeah yeah
I actually thought about it you did
think yeah I actually thought about it
cuz like I'm talking all this [__] about
it maybe I should actually do it yeah
maybe I should [__] and I was trying
to justify he go he probably did [__] my
mom but he was getting underneath my
skin you know so so I grew up in an
environment of sexually charged
psychological warfare right and we
[__] tag team girls two of us we've
been competing to [__] competing
against each other fighting over this
chick [__] doing [__] [__] going
down on her and stuff and [__] trying to
compete to see who could send her over
the [__] Moon and
we man I'm [__] telling too much of
my stories now but uh you've already
told the story that's everybody knows
everything about us I don't think we've
I don't think there's a single thing
yeah about us that we've haven't said on
this grandr knows about it he's we Have
No Secrets from anyone I don't know if
grandr is in the comment section he went
to high school with he was earlier I
don't know where he went me and [__]
Steve Steve had this basement little
apartment he built down there was he did
the walls and the structures and
everything he had real [__] [__]
plywood [__] boards and [__] [__]
it was a real to topc
room and that was like the pleasure
Palace down
there we get high in there and [__]
smoke weed drop acid and [__] and
[__] had a phone down there we'd
[__] call girls we get them to come
over but uh it would start we would
start talking [__] about some chick that
we were looking at we'd talk about her
for hours what she looked like and [__]
[__] we start thinking about what it
was she was going to be like and then we
why don't you call her and we We call
we sometimes we get him to come over and
she get to come over here and blow us
well we wouldn't do it that
way well no you can't say that on the
phone you got to like have a little bit
of finesse come on we' invite him to a
concert even if you're a teenager so you
want to go to the you want to go to the
[__] Stevie rayon concert with us we
got an extra te you want to go see Rick
Springfield yes
got got extra ticket he yeah yeah you
can come with us if you want she goes
well who are you going you know who you
know he like who else is going it's just
just me and Steve and our reputation was
out there and then they're like they
like oh okay just you two yeah yeah just
us yeah I'm going go to the restroom can
you can you get me a drink on your way
back yeah
yeah I mean I don't have to
drive Zach asked why your face was so
shiny is it shiny I think there was just
like a light kind of shining on your uh
cheek maybe that's what it was kayin
hiin says trauma is difficult to deal
with especially when it finds its way
into sex yeah I agree and the toxic
people they're attracted to men and
women can't save people who don't want
to be saved yeah I mean like I said I'm
not saying that's like the most healthy
way to deal with [__] but I understand
why some people might deal with it in
that way because that's like I said
that's they feel like they were in a
situation where they had all their power
and their control like taken away from
them and they want to like reestablish
that
and if that's the way they do it like I
said they should probably go to a
therapist but you know it might help
them I don't really know I don't really
know Jeffy art said uh buy a much lesser
extension Hallmark because they indulge
folks need for Nostalgia yeah I've never
been a real big fan of I like written
erotica like I said it's got to be like
erotica I don't really like romance
novels I know a lot of women do um I
read some when I was younger and I was
just kind of like n this isn't really
for me because it seemed like kind of
unrealistic um you know it's like it's
kind of smudy and that's nice but it's
just kind of like I didn't really like
that
whole oh my God I met this millionaire
that's ripped and he's kind of gruff but
I'm gonna you know convince him to fall
in love with M like I don't know I don't
I don't really like that whole [__]
narrative it just seemed really and it
seems like every Romance movie like and
every Hallmark movie is like that and
I'm just kind of like please stop it
it's like that's not the way the world
works and it's just I don't know it just
kind of pisses me off but I do kind of
like um more it's muddy erratica you
know what I mean I don't really like
romance novels though or and I don't
like um romantic comedies either I
really don't like those like chick
flicks I don't I'm I'm just not into it
um y bad dwell is back oh yeah they're
back yeah we're uh we're here every
Friday getting drunk and talking about
[__] this is our Sidetrack show
which we started because when we were
doing one or two shows a week we used to
just do a regular show and a movie
review and we started going off topic so
much who that no I'm they saying that's
why we started the srack show to start
with oh yeah orange juice that's right
yeah we got orange juice um I'm not
drink anymore CU I'm going to drive yeah
like I said but I can have one more
though yeah um we're going to leave in
we're going to leave it around nine yeah
9ish so we got like about another 20
minutes I'm like pretty much ready I
just got to go pee and get my purse and
everything but um but yeah so we started
doing the Sidetrack show because we kept
going off on all these [__] tangents
and I thought oh well maybe we'll get it
all out of our system on the Sidetrack
show and we'll actually be able to stay
on topic on the Regular Show yeah did
that work out of course it did not no it
just encouraged us to go
offs even more like on the other [__]
but that's okay yeah it's all fun uh
badwell said I'm new I saw that the
creeping flesh review and after that I
was all in on this channel that's well
that's awesome that's awesome that's
funny yeah we've been doing this [__]
since
2016 I think we started the show in 2016
now initially when we started it it was
just like a slideshow we didn't have
like a video component we didn't do
anything like that right around our
200th episode we started doing live
streams and we found that we liked that
much better so now we pretty much just
do all and I do I do reviews like of
movies and books and stuff like that
like on my own that are recorded but
mostly we just do live streams because
it's so much fun it's it's much more fun
I think Zach says I'm going to start
going to a therapist here soon started
an anti-depressant and the last few days
have been hell I think it's messing with
my head I feel super needy right now
yeah I mean I don't I've never messed
with any of that stuff cuz I don't know
I kind of feel like my brain is [__]
up enough as it is I don't really need
to encourage it to go in any weirder
directions you know what I'm saying but
okay deing I all that time I was telling
a story about me and Steve making all
the chicks this is what I look like Jen
said that I look like I had Rick
Springfield hair you did kind of but in
we I love this picture actually me and
Steve looked just like each other in in
this phase back in those days and we
kind of had hair that was pretty much
for us it was more we kind of it was
more we thought it was more like the
hair that like something out of YouTube
like something Bono would have well yeah
I mean Bono kind of everybody kind of
had hair like that back in the day but
that's what I look like look at baby Tom
that's what I looked like back then
teenage Tom yeah that's why he was
that's why he was getting all the ladies
super pretty yeah it was pretty as [__]
real pale in the snow up in
Michigan [__] in high school ruining
them girls just ruin them me and Steve
were like yeah we're g to get that one
we're gonna we're GNA [__] ruin her
no no dude will ever be able to match
what we're going to do to her she's
every guy is going to be a
disappointment after us I yeah yeah yeah
so it was just now me and Steve didn't
have sex with each other but we would
have sex with that girl at the same time
right Devil's threesome
I've never actually done that only three
Sims we've done it is like it been
another girl but but like I said I'm
kind of more into that because I am kind
of into girls too
so I don't know I don't know how I feel
about two
dudes nobody's asking you to do it well
you know nobody's asking it would depend
like I said I'm not averse I'm just
saying it would depend on the situation
for me I'd have to be real tight with a
dude well I would too I would I would
have to like know the I'm not
Rando that would be like creepy and
weird like it's not something that I
think about any I had be super tight
with him and have to know [__] he's
actually no threat he's not going to run
off with anybody he's not going to try
you know if he was married that's
[__] even better yeah you know what I
mean [__] I mean I'm kind of I don't
know Tom it's just like I'm kind of like
all you like yeah I mean I like girls
and stuff but it's just kind of like
with the devil's three some wouldn't be
doing that for anything other than
[__] basically for [__] video make
a movie that'd be you know and even
we now we've done it virtually yeah like
on stream mate all the time we do it on
there a lot yeah like because we get a
lot of um like bisexual guys that will
come on and they want to like kind of
pretend that they're they're like in
right right and so we've done that
before but it's like they're not here
and like they're just you know they're
just like on cam to cam or whatever so
it's like not the same thing yeah on
stream mate if you're streaming as a
couple bisexual guys are your especially
young bisexual guys they're the best
clients to work for oh big time because
they're not picky they're just like can
you guys put on a good show for me you
guys are so high this and that just and
it was what and they're into both of us
so that's cool yeah and they're like uh
is anything he want goes no no no just
have a good time man [__] you know
just take me on a journey like okay yeah
the ones that are [__] more more like
that are bisexual guys in the UK British
guys bi British guys are great they're
easy to work can I just say that like on
streamate at least in our experience
British guys
are like a thousand times more polite
than American guys yeah yeah they are
very very polite they are always very
nice they are always very respectful
they're also a lot of Americans are too
but it's just like the British it kind
of stands out like the British are a lot
more the British guys tend to be doing
this on stream mate while they're at
work yeah I noticed that yeah they you
know in NE and man I'm at work I'm
[__] horny as [__] you guys help me
oh yeah yeah yeah what is you looking
for just anything just yeah he's like
they're not picking like I said I found
I found that the more picky or the more
specific people's fantasies are like the
the more of a pain in the ass they and
and the worse the show is going to be
yeah because it's just kind of like
because you're like Che it off a list
yeah you're like afraid that you're
going to mess it up because it's like oh
it's not because they want this very
very specific scenario yeah they want a
specific scenario and it's usually
something we don't really care much
about and it's not really coming from
the heart you're just going through a
damn checklist of what the dude want
wanted to see yeah whereas like if if
you just said go crazy okay we're going
to go crazy yeah then we'll just do [__]
that we would normally do like if we
weren't on camera you know what I mean
like going to be a lot more real yeah
because like I said that's what we'd be
doing if we weren't on camera anyway
Bryce says us bisexual guys are nice
people yes I have found that yeah like I
said and that and that tends to be like
our best client so we're always very
very happy like when buy guys come in
and like yeah the straight guys are
going to be more the like the checklist
type guys most of them and they tend to
be a little bit more demanding like I
said um not always but a lot of them
some of them aren't picky but like some
of them do tend to want to see picky
[__] me get roughed up that's like
pretty common they well that's BDSM type
guys yeah yeah yeah like they want to
see me get smacked around or choked or
whatever so there's a lot of that yeah
which a lot of that well we've done it
it's yeah we've done it sometimes that's
about 15% of it
probably but it's like pro wrestling you
know you're doing it but you're pulling
your punches [__] not pull not
punching but making sure the slaps are
not that hard yeah like I said yeah he's
not going to like hurt me for real he
would never do that the dude says slap
you he's just why you can you slap her
says can you slap her hard I said well
how hard are you talking about as hard
as you can I said dude I'd knock her out
you probably would okay well don't hurt
her I said yeah yeah
yeah yeah you better not I could knock I
could knock I'll kill you while you
sleep I could knock a grown man out
[__] with a s that's what I mean if
you really knowwhere to slap I [__]
bow [__] yeah if you SLA me in the
face yeah you probably knocked me out so
you got to be there are sweet spots
where you can slap somebody and [__]
then you pow like that it'll [__] set
him right down yeah and it wouldn't
matter if it's a slap or punch it's
mostly just
location bad dwell said I wish I could
do pornos my ding-dongs too little
though there's a thing for that there's
a thing for everything uh to be honest
there's a niche for everything that's
kind of like the wonderful world of porn
um no matter what you have going on
there is somebody out there that will
pay to look at that yeah I have found uh
no matter how strange you might think it
is or you might think oh nobody wants to
see this oh someone absolutely does I
guarantee that there is somebody out
there that wants to see that and will
pay money thank you very much Jeffy art
thanks appreciate it very much what you
say just started watching what we do in
the shadows have you guys seen it I
haven't but I really really want to
watch it because it looks really good
and it looks like right up my alley and
I know it's been out for like a super
long time but I'll eventually get around
to I promise to get por to what he was
saying about you know having a uh to not
being what they would call well
endowed most porn sales is men uh that's
the customer almost everything is
oriented towards the the male buyer
women will watch porn but if you look at
the statistics they don't they don't buy
it okay no why would I pay for it the
man will buy it yeah if you were not
well endowed there's a couple things
that you could do to make money on that
it would be kind of
like um like a cuck fetish type thing
and that's big like a lot of people have
that especially if it was had a
homosexual lean to it in other words
you're
selling this kind of like [__]
emasculation cuck little dick fantasy to
a gay dude who was also not well owed
and you you kind of have a resonate
frequency setting off but we're you know
about your little dicks you know what I
mean [__] you'd have to research it I
never I know it's out there I haven't
watched it you have to
research what it is they're making what
the content is actually like and then
you goes okay well I can make this kind
of video this one and this one and this
you put them on a list of what what you
can little genres you can fill in niches
in the
market but no there's there's porn for
that the buyer is going to be gay and
well and I mean [__]
fetish is much more common than you
might think yeah a lot of people have
that and we have like a lot of people
coming and ask him for that kind of
stuff and they they want Tom to cuck
them out yeah like they they want to
pretend that I'm their girlfriend or
their wife or something like that and
Tom is like stealing me yeah that's and
making fun of the size of his and making
fun of that's another thing a lot of
dudes want you to make fun of like how
smaller someone will go cam to cam
they're showing a c they're showing a
camera shot of themselves and [__]
how big they
are and to be honest half the time the
dudes that are into that they're they're
not little they're average they're just
average to Lear it's fantasizing that is
it's ler than it is that's some weird
[__] too man although we did have I will
say I don't you know there were some
that's very little there was a guy I
think it was Irish yeah we've had him in
a couple of times and his whole thing is
he has like a pretty small penis okay
just you know much smaller than average
and his whole thing is he really gets
off on showing it to people and have
people comment on how small it is yeah
um because he would keep saying stuff
like to Tom like oh my God like even
when you're not hard like you're so much
bigger than me and blah blah blah so he
was like getting off on I got to rub it
in his face that yeah so it's like a lot
of them do kind of get off on that it's
super weird like it's weird I mean it's
not weird I guess I can't really relate
to it but I I know what it is asking for
so yeah cuz you know Tom's packing so
he's just kind of like now bad done well
says his is 6 and a half inches which is
too small for
porn no that's not true that is
absolutely not how tall are you
everything has to do with proportions 6
and a half inches is actually above
average yeah so I don't know I think you
don't have to have like a huge slong for
porn you really don't yeah like not
everybody in porn I think that's kind of
a misconception that like all the dudes
in porn have like [__] 11in [__] or
whatever they absolutely don't a lot of
them are just like reg like just like
average to above average yeah because
they're not the main selling point
unless it's gay porn that's another uh
Niche but in straight porn the dudes as
long as they have like a kind of a
respectable size dick and they're not
really the um the main selling point the
woman is so it doesn't really matter as
long as you can like keep it up the
whole time then you're gold according to
like
what girls are asking for on tnder and
dating sites
their basic requirements is is 666 six
feet tall with a sixpack and at least
six inches of dick right so you're more
than that so you're actually in the more
respectable that's what I'm saying
that's above average as far as I'm aware
now there are ethnic differences okay
whites Asians blacks people from India
um I've seen the the data on all that
there each there's a different median
median average in there uh and
um whites and blacks are towards the the
top of the scale the averages are
towards the top of the scale the the
other ones their averages are cons
considerably smaller uh at 6 and a half
inches in Korea you'd be considered big
now what's
big on a SK on a ruler and what's big in
the camera is two different
things like I'm about seven but I'm only
5 foot six
so on my proportions it looks big you
know it's like uh just like short girls
with boobs you know lot of short girls
have big boobs but if you actually put
that boob on a on a taller taller girl
wouldn't look that big
yeah yeah so you don't I mean you do
have a big dick but it's just kind of
like yeah yeah it probably looks bigger
because you're not super there are some
black performers out there they're even
shorter than me 5'4 55 those dudes are
packing like nine inches but it looks
like [__] 13 on a [__] 5 foot4
frame you
know so it's
bonus I mean I will note that you have
had uh friends of ours like see you in
the men's room and be like holy crap Tom
like and and some people have like um
bought our videos yeah and commented
it's not that big it's optical
illusion it is big but it's not you know
proportions it's not freaky big no but
it's definitely like above average yeah
I would guess yeah well for for 56 it's
big yeah
yeah looks bigger than it
is objects in Mirror are larger than
they appear yeah yeah uh Rachel says
nine is huge by the way it is yeah n is
huge it's
massive well like I said and I've seen
some porn videos with like dudes with
like big like [__] like and big
around and [__] like that and in a way
it's just kind of like it's not it's not
hot really because it's just kind of
like wow that's kind of like freaky
looking and it's like wow that would
hurt I have some dildos out size and
it's like I don't know
yeah there there are some painful female
performers that make videos that are
just the worship of [__] size and
girth right lot of sometimes they don't
even have sex with the dude it's just
all oral stuff and manual
stuff they got size queens they got
women there oh yeah into that yeah like
I said I'm kind of more concerned about
the person it's attached to um and and
we were talking about this the other day
because we were watching some porn while
we were on stream mate and some dude had
this [__] massive ass dick and I was
just and we were just kind of like in a
way that has to be a little bit of a
handicap because it's like nobody can
get their mouth on much of it's not like
you can have some woman like deep
through the whole thing or like that you
can't even get it in your [__] mouth
it's too big so it's just kind kind of
like that's got to be kind of cuz like
chicks would be trying to like give him
head and stuff and it's just like it
only go down like this far like dude it
doesn't it doesn't fit in there the
dudes that are packing that much so they
don't give a [__] got so much swag and
you know they don't yeah they just like
yeah I'm just going to wrap it around my
leg I don't care yeah but um [__] our
friend Toby's like that he is yeah yeah
that leather daddy friend of mine yeah
[__] he's
gigantic well yeah obvious and we know
that we've never seen him naked but we
know that because it's you can see it
through his like wraps around well his
boyfriends have said [__] well and that
too we've known people that have had sex
with him he's a white dude you know Tobe
if you don't knew this show he's a white
dude he's a leather
daddy [__] uh in good shape he's in
his 50s now he still looks great and uh
pretty much only [__] with black dudes
he likes real tough [__] black dudes
that are [__] hanging that's that's
his thing and uh he's the size King you
know yeah and he's he's [__] huge too
[__] he'll be out there dancing one
time me and Jed were [__] we were
both loaded he's dancing out there on
the [__] D for he's wearing his
[__] PVC skin tight [__]
suit and
uh [__] there was some girls watching
him dance he's dancing all [__] girls
[__] love him he's an awesome dancer
yeah he's and they're just sitting there
[__] looking at his crotch with their
[__] B and I said Chen look look look
at those girl they just sitting there
it's [__] [__] and it's [__] the
size of a [__] b 40 oz beer
can going to the left which means he's a
right-handed man okay and it went around
his [__] leg and it looked like he
had a [__] peach or something on the
[__] look like a WRA looked like a
rolled up tow with a [__] Peach it
did actually and and [__] I'm going
look at that look at and it was just
funny like godamn them girls are going
God
damn like I kind of like we we've known
him a long time so it's like not that
big of a deal but it's just kind of like
it's funny like watching other
people reacting to it yeah he was
dressed like an incubus for [__] for
Halloween cuz we saw him ons like this
past Saturday P yeah PVC he had the best
costume I thought PVC pants great tall
[__] uh [__] um new rock boots
expensive new rock boots a little
[__] short vest long that was
PVC he's hairy ass hairy [__] pretty
good build on him he's in good shape and
I think he's older than we are I think
he's
56 he had a f he's got a [__] beard
like a [__]
Spartan and he had a mask on with
horns he had a pitchfork didn't he no he
didn't have Pitchfork no he didn't have
Pitchfork he had devil wings he had
[__] devil wings [__] bat wings
coming off it was a cool outfit it
looked really good got there dancing and
that [__] he always looks good though
yeah he goes all out bondage stuff on I
said he's also a good dancer which is
always like a good because you're a d
good dancer too I don't like he's a
biker yeah he's a biker too I don't like
dudes that can't dance I mean I don't
want to say I don't like them I'm just
saying that it's just kind of like I'm
kind of one of those people that it's
like if you can't dance yeah then you
probably can't [__] either that's what
aella that hooker that million dollar
hooker that's she said I mean in my
experience that has been the case she
said she I'm sure it's not always the
case she says if you impress me at the
[__] on dance for the club you're
getting free [__] that's what she said
that's what I said I think that was
maybe the first thing that made me
notice you like other than like you were
always like a real good dresser and
stuff CU you used to do like the whole
vampire [__] and everything um but I was
like man that [__] can dance yeah which
a lot of dudes can't yeah a lot of dudes
can't well actually a lot of white
people can't but uh especially white
dudes white dudes are really not good
dancers they don't focus on it and
what's I'm sit there looking at like
they're just shuffling it's like are you
listening to the music at all or and
what's a shame is that the dudes that
the white dudes that you think could
dance can't dance like you'll have
athletes out there who are all about the
the human body in human performance and
the [__] can't dance yeah why
is that what the [__] is that you would
think that they would more than anyone
would have kind of like the an awareness
of what their body is doing and like
some Rhythm or something you see a
badass [__] out there dancing
you go you go and and and he's [__]
covered in tattoos and he's an MMA
fighter and he can [__] dance dudes
that can dance can fight because it's
very similar you know [__] it it's
fighting fighting is a form of dance
even there's a Brazilian martial art
called Capa which was like African
martial arts masquerading his
dancing see that's what I'm saying it's
like
honestly if you look at dud learn to
dance yeah all those all those that will
you will go far if you learn dance all
all those [__] martial artists uh
[__] uh which is Jackie Chan I think
even Bruce
Lee they were [__] martial artists
but they started in [__] Hong Kong
theater yeah where they were doing dance
dance training yeah that that's where
they start yep well and that's the thing
like um even when I was a kid and I'm
not super coordinated to be honest I
think I'm a good dancer but I'm not like
super coordinated but when I was a
little kid um I took dance classes I
took ballet I took Jazz I took
acrobatics I used to be able to do back
bends and back flips and all that kind
of [__] I don't think I could do it
anymore because I'm too old but um but
yeah I used to be able to do all that
stuff and it like and it sticks with you
so I don't know I kind of feel like uh
that's one thing that's another bit of
advice that I would give to dudes is
please learn to dance because honestly
and we're Goths so we're [__] so we
go to the club and we see some Normy
there and it's like out there trying to
trying to dance to a song we were just
like mercilessly we're not going to do
it like to his face cuz that's mean but
we'll like just sit there with each
other and like Snicker like look at that
[__] the [__] is he even doing
like what the [__] song is he even
listen to is he even listen to a song
He's just kind of like they just Shuffle
around I don't really get it honestly I
would rather see somebody and we know
some people like this I would rather see
somebody that was like not a great
dancer but they just like [__] went
for it you know what I mean and they
were just doing crazy [__] and
everything like that not stupid crazy
[__] like woo like all that kind of crap
but it's just kind of like where they
were like super into it and they're like
all operatic and whatnot like I would
rather that than just some dude that was
out there
going just like shuffling around I mean
that is just lame lame you know what I'm
saying so yeah Rachel says I've been
listening to you guys since almost the
beginning your shows and Jenny's reviews
have gotten me through my mom's early
onset dementia her passing my divorce
and a cancer diagnosis is holy [__]
[__] that is awesome that's awesome I
it's like it's funny because we do this
show and it's just like for us it's just
kind of fun we're hanging out with you
guys and talking about [__] or
whatever it is we're talking about but
that I don't know that just kind of um
that means a lot to me that you say that
that we're actually like maybe kind of
helping people in a way you know getting
them through well cuz I said that um
somebody named uh Rachel she said she'd
been listening to you guys on since the
beginning and said your shows and
Jenny's reviews have gotten me through
my mom's early onset dementia her
passing my divorce and a cancer
diagnosis oh damn answer you got no oh
yeah that's that's what I mean so it's
just kind of
like I don't know like maybe this silly
show that we do is like actually helping
people which is actually nice that
actually kind of makes me feel good
about there's always little nooks and CR
little [__] crannies of [__]
advice and [__] that we kind of try to
weave into a lot of the shows and
experience es that we've had like I said
dudes learn to dance that's another
piece of it learn to [__] dance I
can't understand why jocks don't know
how to [__] dance they really don't
they'll [__] go on I heard once a
long time ago this was back in the 70s
that one of those [__] teams I think
it might have been the Rams that the
owner made them all go to dance class I
remember hearing about that like made
them do like ballet or something and
they were all like what that's so [__]
blah blah blah and they got like all
upset about it but then they were like
oh now I see yeah ballet is hard y'all I
used to do it well um what it was is it
it increases the Mind Body Connection
and the control over the human body
which would end up in sports allowing
you to duck and weave and Bob yeah and
[__] change direction a lot
better um because
uh in a fight or a life and death type
situation you can't there's no time to
think about anything the body must
automatically resp respond to stimulus a
good example
is motorcycling I've been riding
motorcycles since uh well on the street
I started in
1994 but I was riding Freewheelers and
dirt
bikes starting in
uh maybe
1980 so I got a lot of experience on two
wheels and three too that was out in the
dirt dirt is where you learn a lot of
good [__]
especially about losing traction and
breaking traction you can learn that on
the dirt how to control a bike that's
[__] drifting or force a drift that
kind of
stuff over the years decades over the
decades
really motorcycle physics and the
controls have been so hardwired into my
nervous
system that things have happened on that
motorcycle that would would have been
catastrophic for somebody else like
avoiding a high side or [__]
regaining traction after you lose the
front end and deep in a turn because you
hit pie needles or something like that
or you hit
sad I got into deep trouble and got out
of
it in about a second and if you were to
ask me how I got out of that I wouldn't
be able to tell you because I wasn't in
charge it was just like the autonomic
nervous system did it I don't know how I
got out of it it just did
um it was all just by
feel so there was one where I was going
through an intersection in a deep left
left hand turned and went across the
center of the intersection and there was
a bunch of sand and [__] that had piled
up in that in that in that intersection
where the cars had pushed it into like a
square and the front wheel went in there
went through that as I was leaned over
dabed near dragging a knee when it
happened and I lost the front end the
front end started to slide away from me
and I'm went oh [__] and then the next
thing I know I was [__] through the
turn traction back on and on the
throttle and tried to go back in time
how did I get out of
that uh
slide and I really couldn't tell you I
think I just applied a bunch of throttle
yeah you can't think about it because
there's no time it just there's
something about your system gets your
nervous system is
hardwired to do things before you even
think about it it just reacts in a
certain way
well dance can help you get that
automatic response with unthinking this
with your physical body especially in
relation to another person because there
you're dancing with
somebody that translates into fights too
if you can take somebody who's like that
and then start training them to punch
and kick properly and how to duck and
weave duck and Bob and weave that person
could become very effective and they and
they say how did you beat that dude up
and they're going to say I don't know
just
did it just happened automatically
that's how I roll little
swole he was the punching bag for his
older brother and his older brother was
a semi-pro this a friend of ours by the
way I call him little swo and he's just
a little short dude 55 54 and if you
look at there's nothing to
him that dude is deadly he knocked out
two Irish dudes he bust your ass yeah he
knocked out two Irish dudes you would
never know right in front the police
station [__] orange a and what was at
the pizza place right and the pizza
place
yeah knocked both of them out and under
three seconds and nobody saw it happen
he walked away and there's [__]
stealthy as [__] yeah and [__] he
walked away there were two dudes out
there [__] sleeping and twitching on
the ground two Irish dudes he was just
like Po yeah it was and he only threw
two punches yep both of them
[__] head shot to the [__] jaw
uppercuts I think he said one of them
was an uppercut the other one was was
another kind of [__] roundhouse and
and they didn't know it hit him nope and
they they judged him by his looks which
I do that I judge people by their looks
you can't though but you can't do that
all the time nope all right cuz you
would never know this D well in a way I
think that works to his Advantage yeah
because he's not I mean he's not like
small small but he's probably my height
yeah's a little short guy maybe a little
bit taller than me he's a little bit pot
bellied and he's not muscular he's fast
though and very very
skilled you [__] with him he will knock
your ass out like in a second you won't
know he can defeat multiple opponents
quickly yeah and he he'll release videos
of himself [__] working on the
punching bags and [__] and his to hear
his [__] blows it's like rapid fire
gunshots and every one of those blows is
hitting hard and he's I wouldn't [__]
with him that's for sure yeah and he's a
really nice he's a really nice person
he's a really nice Hur of [__] little
bony fist but if you [__] with him he
will cave your face in yeah and then
sneak away and then walk away like it
didn't happen like I said he's like
super stealthy yeah like I said that
probably works to his Advantage because
he doesn't look like he's not walking
down the street like you are with like
big old [__] arms [__] you would
never notice like he's just like real
Incognito yeah they did something to
him they went by pushed him or something
yeah like I don't remember him and
[__] got the pizza place pizza place
around the corner from where independent
bar used to be like in downtown Orlando
which you know it's kind of a [__] up
it's kind of [__] up there was a
couple of drunk Irish tourists and they
saw and they started [__] with yeah
they saw a little dude they they were
going to squeeze him he [__] him up
and left them both there sleeping on the
side they were just both on the sidewalk
yeah just knocked out like I said right
from the police station because right
next to the pizza place is the police
station and they were you know these are
the guys that are 5'10 5'8 you know much
bigger than him much bigger
[__] that was it I think he said he
only threw two punches like I said my
knock out with both one hit quitters two
of them just don't [__] with anybody I
mean why would you [__] with somebody
well when you look when you look at Lil
swo you wouldn't think he was could
bring it he doesn't have that demeanor
he doesn't have that look in his face he
doesn't but he can because he was the
punching bag for his little for his old
he got used to like being he was just
used as a punching bag a St a [__]
sparring partner for a semi-pro
boxer
mhm like I said you can't judge anybody
so just don't [__] with anybody because
you don't know who's going to [__]
kill you at any given time like I said
not everybody comes at you like Tom who
looks like a big buff psycho you know
what I mean I am a psycho well you are a
psycho yeah pretty confirmed yeah yeah
you are a psycho well we were talking
about that before like but you know yeah
not in a mean way no but you are kind of
crazy
yeah kind of he yeah kind of when it
when it's called for yeah I mean like I
said if if some bad [__] went down you
probably do want Tom on your side though
because he will [__] some [__] up yeah
it's been on your it's been confirmed
yes like I said I've had him defend me
many times yeah yeah and I got I got a I
got a historical [__] I got a history
behind me that [__] it's all there
confirmed documented confirm document
yeah Sign Sealed delivery yeah it's
all which I don't know if we've ever
talked about that but yeah yeah no I
haven't talked about that yeah Danny
Rowling said would Jenny and Tom ever
revisit some of their past movie reviews
you've done for a spoiler review to get
more in-depth of the films we might do
that actually um we have thought about
that because I know we did some movie
reviews like a long time ago that we
probably wanted to revisit or talk about
more so yeah that is a total possibility
uh bad done well was talking about
earlier having the six and a half inch
dick also said I'm slightly under six
feet very skinny I got a David bowiesque
build and a pretty face I'm just like
yeah nothing wrong with that yeah at all
yeah I can understand if you're tall you
know six and a half's going to you're
going to you look in the mirror that's
might look disappointing to you but I
think if I remember correctly average
for Caucasians is more like [__] four
and a half five yeah I thought that yeah
I thought the average was more like five
yeah so six and a half is well over
average and the thing about it have a
[__] 13in get it but it's just kind
of like well and the thing too is like I
don't know if you guys know cuz you
might need be new but for a long time
obviously before he died um I used to
tell Tom that I had this fantasy about
him and David Bowie see I get this [__]
all the time she talking about in The
Labyrinth outfit yeah yeah yeah with the
Jared the Jared pants so it's just kind
of like when we have David Bowie come
over in in The Labyrinth outfit and he
could be an old man that's okay yeah um
no like the same age as he was in the
film I mean yeah but it's just like I'm
I'm it's it's cool I'm I'm I'm open to
it cuz he still looked good he still
looked good like when he was an old man
I was just like he good art until he
died that's what I mean I was like um
I'd still hit so so yeah right up until
he died and he was in the 70s yeah so
it's just kind of like for so for a long
time so that kind of bummed me out like
I was really upset when he died because
we like we're both huge David Boe fans
yeah and um so when he died it was
almost kind of like uh it I I never I
don't usually get upset by celebrity I
think that was the only time that I
actually like [__] busted out crying
from a celebrity dying like multiple
times it was time for him to go he he he
did he he lived a long life he he lived
a [__] [__] awesome life he lived
awesome he he went back to the Black
Star he's up there with [__] Major
Tom on the Black Star I hope so yeah
yeah I hope so I mean he's like the
whole he left some good artwork behind
and good music behind and his [__] was
that dude was the [__] yeah what time is
it it's 9:12 okay it's time we got to
[__] uh go bad dwell also said I love
talking about this kind of stuff with
people in a safe and open-minded
environment yeah so do we that's why we
like doing this ni
show because it's F we could talk about
anything on here and everyone's just
like okay with it you know what I mean
Bryce says I first listened to you guys
with the Mr cruel episode oh [__] I
remember that that was a long time ago
forg about that I couldn't remember you
guys' names and rediscovered you when a
goth friend suggested you guys oh nice
all right isn't it crazy like it's so
crazy like and he's in New Zealand right
so it's just kind of like oh my God all
kind of stuff Hi Desert said I miss
David Bowie I do see that to be honest
with you yeah he left a lot of good
music behind though he's with us always
we will rejoin with him when we go back
to the ploma we still I still have like
a bunch of his songs old ones and new
ones like on our on my Spotify so we
listen to him on the way to the club
like all the time yeah people forget
those two albums that he did with tin
machine they were good too yeah I didn't
like that as much as the solo stuff but
yeah Tim machine was Tim machine was
hard it was like a real hard rock it was
good I liked it yeah all right so we are
going to have to head out to the club in
a bit yeah I got to I'm pretty much all
ready I just got to get my phone and
[__] like that so it'll be all right get
my [__] together you get your [__]
together also but yeah so thanks for
dropping by and hanging out with us on
this Friday night Sidetrack show getting
drunk with us whatever it is you're
doing out there we will be back again on
Monday night for a movie review not sure
which one we're going to talk about I
watched one earlier which was kind of I
don't want to spoil it but it's like it
was from the 70s I had never heard of it
before I saw it on some like underrated
movies of the 70s I'm like what the [__]
is this I never heard of this movie and
somebody had put it up on YouTube so I
watched I'm like wow this is pretty good
and kind of [__] up kind of a southern
gothic kind of vibe to it and I was
telling Tom about it he's like I kind of
want to [__] watch that so it's like
so maybe we might so I might watch it
again so he can see it and we might
review that but we might review
something totally different I'm not
really sure if we don't I'll do a review
of that by myself you know what I mean
because I got to talk I have I have
emotions about this movie and I have to
[__] talk about it but yeah I I kind
of want to show it to Tom though because
I'm like you're not going to believe
this [__] you got to like [__] watch
it but yeah so we're going to go out
hopefully have a good time this evening
and not get any fights but we'll see how
it goes so we'll see you guys again on
Monday please have a good weekend good
night